[Music]
so it's the highest you've ever slept at
almost a while when you don't have a
fear of heights it's not really scary
it's like being in the craziest creepy
house that you can possibly imagine
that's Marc's in it he's a professional
rock climber and he's talking about
sleeping in a tent
they're called total Ledger's that's
hanging off the side of a mountain he's
been climbing for over 30 years and his
favorite walls to climb are really
really high alpine big wall climbing is
the pursuit of scaling the biggest
cliffs on planet Earth oh yes they take
a few days to summit so he has to camp
out along the way so I want to know what
does it feel like to sleep in a
portaledge hanging off the side of a
mountain the one thing that's more or
less ever-present in the mountains is
wind it can be pretty violent you can
experience hurricane-force winds there's
also this thing that we call the Bronco
ride wind comes in hits a cliff and it
really has nowhere to go except for up
eventually it hits you and you're ledge
and it can lift the whole thing up so
you can be suspended and then of course
the ledge that slams into the wall
you're just thinking about surviving and
that wasn't the worst of it
the smell in the ledges is not it's not
nice you don't change your clothes you
don't bathe it's wicked scummy but
people love it they continue to climb
and explore do all of this punishment
because there's still that one question
left
how does it feel the way it makes you
feel is like a tiny speck of dust very
empowering it really is just like kind
of the most spectacular spot that you
could be on planet earth right after
school
and just like shiny like one to the gym
so I can climb it it's a dangerous all
right but I only think that I'm afraid
of it not being able to get to this
office
[Music]
it's climbing I don't think that it
really matters with how big you are
if you're smaller you can hold on longer
and your hands might be small ways so I
can fit my finger it's on hold I started
climbing in Central Park when I was six
years old now I don't think I can like
live without it
[Music]
when we're close to the top of the time
you're trying to do your funds usually
feel like they're gonna explode and
they're gonna like first open and you
feel like you have to let go but it's
climbing you just can't let go I think
that climbing is it's obviously a sport
but it's also like a dance you sort of
have to be able to like flow up the wall
and come up with your own techniques to
get to accomplish
I think people shocked if I do something
that they can't do is something because
I'm still really young and I'm a girl so
like doing something that even if a guy
can't do it Devils Tower is an amazingly
special place
[Music]
it's just up and out of the Prairie like
what happened here
[Music]
there's something inexplicable but
happily undeniable about the power of
Devil's Tower I'm Frank Sanders then I
am a professional rock climbing guide
not sure how I got here but this shoe
really fits I've been climbing since I
was 15 so I guess I've been climbing 50
years I'm 65 years old still doing it
first time I saw The Devil's Tower up
real and close was June of 1972 and that
night the sky was full of lightning the
flashes the booms illuminated the tower
I was intimidating sure that's why I
came all that way to be intimidated
I have somewhere around 2,000 a sense of
the tower the joy in guiding is to be
along when somebody else hits that
experience and you get to share it
that's fantastic
The Rock wants to be climbed and if you
looked at the Rock The Rock will show
you right word touch and how hard to
touch
right on partner the tower is a ever
ready partner I don't want to sound too
trippy here but you touch it it touches
you getting to the top of the towers
both the physical and an emotional
spiritual journey it looks like I can't
do it but then in your heart you believe
you can be on top to be honest with you
for me it was a letdown we've run out of
rock to climb right now Devil's Tower
if I had to pick one word is home for me
I'm happy
[Music]
normally Pancho's realizing for kunchi
to say it was open yet you read American
tire changes I moved to go to dong
pioneers own country to cultivate an
energy Pampa
this region of Guangzhou China is famous
for its sprawling mountains rivers and
massive caves it's here that a
little-known ancient Miao tradition of
cave based rock climbing is carried on
by a few locals known as spider-man
which are one phones own junior was
Sanjaya how many PI N Trade Towers so we
know the EMP sang fanta sea iguana this
Miao burial tradition faded into
obscurity and what remained was a unique
method of collecting rare medicinal
herbs that some say remedy diseases such
as asthma and rheumatism the spider-man
with their unparalleled climbing skills
are the only people who can get them so
you're tied to PC Italian piece and set
it out over a piece on I'm Python she
title your tree or she also chose hood I
think we like vomiting on you go train
game with a hot chick or opinion that's
a Shinigami isn't that how you go this
time to go paella we are not empty
Osamu McDonald juice on what we shall
lay dying which is a week or need to do
then Gigi intent on telling food Sandhya
to in would've of future would you come
whenever by John Waters suing watch it
pal at the hotel jungle unions and she
watches passenger
zanko yo-yo chalet jamaaliday Tina their
move without you where Park
[Music]
oppai and I'm Tony watch was there when
she went away and on what you are
condoned annealing each other memento
what they would show he to go pee Lindo
when people say they summit for the view
I think they're missing a lot of the
equation of why we do the things we do
the summit honestly is pretty
anticlimactic the movement is for me the
most exciting part
my name is Erik Weihenmayer and I'm the
first blind person to have climbed the
tallest peak in every continent
[Music]
when I was four or five years old I was
diagnosed with this incredibly rare
disease called retinas jeesus it
attacked my retinas and essentially
unravel them when I finally went blind
it was a weird relief like the worst
thing had happened so there's nothing
else to lose
there was a recreational group taking
blind kids rock climbing and that was it
for me it was sort of the full package
of adventure all the things I thought I
wouldn't have as a blind person you need
14 for this pitch yeah I'm counting them
right now okay
when I get on to a rock face I actually
feel like I'm in my element
the things that sighted people learn to
do with their eyes I've learned to do
with my hands
when I'm clipping a bolt to a carabiner
I'm feeling it I'm making sure it's
correctly clipped and if I fall that
that carabiner is gonna hold me
[Music]
I can't look up the rock and see the
holds and plan a big route I can only
see as far as my hands
it's breathtakingly excited sometimes
you hear those cars way down below you
in the floor of the canyon
I love that sound of emptiness a lot of
external stuff sort of disappears and
you're thinking about nothing but that
next hold in front of you
so it's very very meditative very much
kind of like an inner mind sport I like
that I think that's the best pitch could
you feel about space like the exposure
down there yeah I mean especially with
these trucks flying by down there you
kind of echoes through the whole canyon
and you can hear everything yeah what do
you say we top out yeah let's um it's
right up here right yeah okay
as a blind climber it's really hard and
you just sort of have to embrace that
suffering blindness is just a thing that
happened to me I think like all
adversities we got to use them as a
catalyst to push you in new directions
it's the idea of turning bad things and
the good things and it's something I
think we all could use